hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie today we're gonna handle
some UI stuff in particular the first
thing I'd like to go over which is this
search input here so I'd like to add a
little icon so that a user could close
the search let's see we had something
like this on another project let me show
you what I'm what I'm thinking about so
I think it'd be something like this you
know what I think we have a bug right
now but you'll be able to see it maybe
no oh well basically what I'd like to
happen is you click this it pops out and
then there's an icon to close it and you
can also click on the search icon and
that will initiate a search so that's
the idea alright so we don't need that
project up right now let's get that out
of the way we do have a gator channel
now so if you're interested in that
check out I don't know what link to give
I guess let me give you this link I
think that'll work I'm gonna paste this
in the live chat now oh I see now the
the camera's frozen from goodness
alright let's move that out of the way
let me grab this one it's just way too
big let's see if we can shrink
I must have I think I was messing with
this at some point and got the
dimensions all messed up it's kind of
odd that it just started happening it
hasn't happened a really long time Wow
oh well so we'll have to make do with
this camera angle I'll try to remember
to look over here if I can but here let
me I have to sit in a different spot
okay all right so that camera and it's
that's too big let's try to shrink that
up
okay all right that looks better
um okay cool so anyway I pasted the link
to that Gator channel in the in the live
chat if I remember I'm gonna have to put
that in the description I keep
forgetting to do that but in case you're
watching and you can't see the link here
maybe you're watching later on you're
just listening
it's get hurt I am / live coding with
Jesse oh I'm sorry it's live coding with
Jesse free code camp so all of that
alright and just want to show you before
we get started a project that one of you
made so Harshit who is a frequent
contributor so I don't know what maybe
for the last month or so very frequent
contributor and so he has made a
Pomodoro timer you all know that I that
I use a Pomodoro timer and I used the
tomato timer well he's made the same
functionality if not more than the
tomato timer and he's done it in react
with Gatsby and then published it with
now which if you're not familiar with
now it's from the same people that made
next Jay s so I think it's I think
insight is the company anyway really
really useful probably I can't really
think of an easier way aside from github
pages to deploy something and get up
pages is somewhat limited but now it's
just a super super easy way to do it and
anyway so if you haven't used that
before I recommend it
anyway so you can see Pomodoro timer can
start it stopped it take long breaks
reset right
it's pretty cool pretty cool so anyway
thanks for sharing that hardship and
also the repo is available so buddy
wants to check that out
Pomodoro - Gatsby is the name of the
repo but looks pretty cool the file that
has most of the the most stuff going on
is the timer ojs so that's that's where
all the the logic is I suppose anyway
really cool so maybe let's use harsh
it's timer today shrink it down a bit
and put it up here in the corner and
since we've started here may as well get
started we're going to do two Pomodoro
sessions today and then questions after
yeah whoo I said we'll see I need to be
done in about an hour or so so I can go
to a meeting and I keep forgetting that
I'm on a different screen now let me see
kinda let me aim this camera better
there we go all right that's more
centered okay
okay well I am getting a call so sorry
about this hello yes
you
all right sorry about that now it's a
great time to give my disclaimer about
this I haven't given this in a long time
but life coding with Jessie is all about
showing what my day-to-day life is like
as a front-end developer so mistakes
included interruptions included so
sometimes I will have somebody knock on
my door at my office and I have to go
talk to them or already a phone call so
that happens I really don't like when
it's that long of a delay because that's
no fun for you all but it's a good
indication so I'm gonna take a minute
and just explain why I think this phone
call was actually ended up being a good
thing so that phone call which took I
don't know 10 minutes maybe was all
about the login system for the bulletin
so one of the reasons why we're redoing
the bulletin so we're redoing this and
we have a new hopefully better login
system and eventually we may even tie it
in with the single sign-on system for
the university so it should be even
better is because I get calls like that
and trying to walk people through how to
sign in in this case it was an old
version of Internet Explorer that was
the problem but then even when switching
to Chrome there was still some confusion
and that's why it took so long so I
think my coworker here who is trying to
access the bulletin can access it now
but I'm still there there was some
trouble so I'm still gonna set up a time
tomorrow or the next day to go over and
check out her computer she could see how
a lot of my time ends up being spent on
that that login so I think it definitely
merits a redo of the bulletin and this
has been out for a year now just about a
year and so for the whole year
I've been you know getting these these
types of calls so there were a lot more
when it first came out so I'd say the
first six months there were a lot more
calls than this last six months but
still you know certainly interrupts the
whatever I'm working on and and can take
up a lot of a lot of time so anyway I
guess the the the moral of the story is
if you do things right the first time
it'll save you a lot of time in the long
run not that I did it wrong I don't
think it's just I I guess at the time I
didn't realize how many people on campus
were using very old versions of browsers
so that was most of the calls that I get
the solution is simply well don't use
Internet Explorer eight anymore or
something like that or Firefox for
uh-huh so anyway all right so let's get
started all right someone had said turn
the mic on is y'all can hear me now
right I did turn the mic on yeah yeah I
thought about leaving the mic on for
that call but then I thought well maybe
this person wouldn't want their
conversation here but I actually I could
of actually there is not really anything
that I said that would have even given
away any secrets you know okay cool okay
so the mic my mic is on now so I just
wanted to verify before I did anything
important all right I'd say you what
next time I get a call if it's a call
like that I'll turn the mic
on and then y'all can hear how I how I
deal with I guess troubleshooting issues
over the phone all right so let's go in
now and let's go into our code and
figure out where this component is and
let's try to get some of that
functionality like I was explaining
earlier so here in this is at bar is an
app bar that JJ s we have we're bringing
in this icon button and that's our
search icon okay and then we have a
handle search toggle and that happens
when that happens at sea
let's see if this handle search dollar
there we go okay so here's where it
comes up so if you're not familiar with
this in react if you're not familiar
with react at all or maybe you're just
starting out with react one of the I
think it's a cool thing but it's also
can sometimes be a confusing thing is
that you can actually pass up actions up
to parent components and then have the
functions that you'd like to be called
on that action actually reside in an
entirely different component and that's
what we have going on here so we had in
an app bar right we have on click handle
search toggle but when we try to find
him it'll search toggle right the only
other place on the page where you have
that is where we're passing in right all
of this so and actually that might be is
that a style for sure some of them are
these are pros
I think the actually these are props
okay so it's just a problem we need to
go up to the parent component which in
this case is index.jsp are we have you
can see our top bar component so in our
top bar component we're passing down
write this function and let's see where
we have and OH handle search toggle so
this is what really gets called even
though it doesn't actually live in that
component
okay Harshit destructuring that's the
word for it I always forget that that's
the word for it so when you break down
the props like we just saw
so you don't basically you don't have to
prep type in this props and then the
prop name every single time it's really
useful if you have a lot of props you
can just be structure and have all the
props get passed into the component you
don't have to worry about using this
props so very useful but here's
basically what what happens and this is
really what we want to what we want to
work on so we change the styles for our
search icon and our search Styles let's
see so let's check out our state use our
search Styles switch icon Styles so in
this case
so we start out with just playing on
display:block okay and let's let's go
back let's let's see it in action all
right so we're gonna inspect now I have
the react dev tools there we go
okay so with our dev tools let's go to
this component which was okay this was
our index component so this should be
able to go in a good top bar I know you
want to go up
stayed there we go
okay so here's is our state right now so
hopefully you can see that over here in
the corner let me make sure I'm not
covering it up okay I'm not alright so
just check this out so in real time we
can see what our state is on that that
top component all right it's not in
terms of the layout folder it's the
route component so we can see our search
icon styles and then our search styles
okay and we can watch them change
actually I should let's see if I can get
them to change by clicking there we go
okay so let's inspect and go to have to
go down a bit oh yeah my too far down
route alright let's go back to the home
page it was hit simpler there okay there
we go
Apolo
there we go so we're in layout I
probably could have found on the other
one I just wasn't patient enough to
click through
if anybody knows of an easier way to
open all this stuff and get down to a
component let me know is search that the
only way that's really easy to do that I
know I have used a search before but I
mean I guess I could find it down here
oh well okay so now let's let's see the
change happen
so right now search icon Styles this
display block search display none and
then when we click this right they flip
okay so that's that's how we do that
transition in in react right so let's
see let's go back here and
let's go to first thing we need to do I
guess is put in those elements that we
want right no sense in putting in a new
state and everything if there's nothing
for it to change seems you've missed an
icon so let me check this oh yeah
top left okay this is
is this what you are talking about this
icon select direct element in the page
to inspect it cool and it takes you
right to it I like that
cool I never knew that awesome thanks
for the advice Harshit and John that's
really cool so if you want to just be
able to click something and go right to
it and react you can click the target
and then and then click right on that
element and it'll take you right to it
really cool let's see okay so let's go
into our at bard rjs and now we want to
we want to add in
we need to add in a close icon then
we're going to need to change some of
the styles for the search icon
okay let me see
okay my timer right now thanks for
reminding me to check the timer so Sony
so harsh it on on your timer I guess you
don't have a sound
I wasn't prompted to allow allow sounds
or anything or allowed notifications
yeah so I didn't hear any audio it's
possible that I just I missed it I
wasn't paying attention but okay so
let's take a short break right now in
between coding sessions we take a five
minute break and I go in the live chat
and answer questions and then at the end
I answer anything that I wasn't able to
get to in our little five-minute session
so let me scroll through and
Oh rob was able to make it awesome I'm
really glad that you could make it
rob head had commented earlier on one of
the videos about not not being able to
make it for the live stream so really
awesome that you did get to make it see
okay so on harshest I'm assuming with
the Pomodoro clock you're talking about
has a bug with github pages that it
redirects to the main page redirects
requests to the main profile which
causes conflicts okay yeah they're
actually I there is it's a little weird
when you're trying to use some some
types of things with like some types of
sites with github pages I've had some
issues before I believe I've found some
workarounds for that but yeah it's not
100% straightforward
let's see her should ask if anyone as
tried Firefox developer edition so it's
really very cool I actually haven't I
haven't tried that so maybe I'll have to
try that out
okay so Anthony asks what are the topics
on this live stream and some of the
responses we're materiai and react
nodejs
express yeah yeah definitely I mean that
pretty much covers it but I guess we use
create react app - you know scaffold the
thing but other than that I think that
does cover everything eventually when we
make this live it's going to sit behind
nginx acting as a reverse proxy so we
may do a little bit of configuration
with nginx but just very minimal
Josh Modi'in says to use Visual Studio
code
I do use Visual Studio code sometimes
did I never actually start this no I
didn't uh I did something okay now it's
working I mean obviously I've already
taken up several minutes but
okay cool Harsha's saying we just
swapped the displays yeah I just I kind
of wanted to show show it like in the
react dev tools just number one just in
case somebody's never used them but then
also just to get the idea for people
coming from like a like a jQuery
mentality more to react that like we're
not we're not directly manipulating the
stuff on the page so if we're changing
state and then based on that state react
does its thing
so I know when I was first starting with
react that was a shift like I had to get
used to that so anyway so I mean
hopefully it was it was helpful
just roadie and what program do you use
oh right now I'm using Adam as my editor
mmm
judge Medina says what do you mainly use
I mainly use Adam so right right now
Adams my primary editor and then
sometimes Visual Studio code so I I keep
thinking about switching to being having
visual studio could be my primary one I
just haven't made that switch yet so
it's a possibility it might happen let's
see okay so I've gotten through
everything in the live chat right now
and I've probably gone over my five
minutes at this point I'm not sure cuz
this this isn't the right time so I'm
gonna go back now okay so it's about
nine minutes after 2 p.m. at my time so
yeah so let's do one I guess we'll try
to get in one more Pomodoro session
mmm
okay let's go back here and okay so we
need to bring in a search icon or I'm
sorry a clothes icon we bring it in
icons okay let's just import another one
here and I'm just gonna guess and say
close and we'll see if it works if
anybody else happens to know what the
real name is let me know otherwise we
might be able to save a few minutes by
just putting that in and we have one
more question so Matt Matt it's correct
me if I'm pronouncing this wrong is it
Matt Mattia or Mattie juh I don't know
let me know I really want to get it
right so Jesse will wrap you here in the
future what do you personally think if
if my future you mean the next like
three years one to three years then yes
definitely if we're talking more like
five years probably but five to ten
years who knows right I mean it's that's
just in computer time it's just way way
too long so harsh is saying reload the
timer page I did I reloaded it and
started again oh you know what maybe
it's the delay in the video so you might
be seeing you might not have seen it yet
so sorry about that see I lost my train
of thought okay we have that icon so
let's throw this icon in and
[Music]
now we're just gonna see if this this
even does anything if it even works so
yep it did great so it was named close
awesome okay so we now have that close
icon and the search icon we don't want
the close icon to be visible by default
though so what we need to do let's see
how we're doing this style search icon
Styles
okay it was Mattia awesome I'm glad I
got it right alright and that goes for
anybody if I ever if I ever pronounced
any of your names wrong please call me
out on it let me know alright so sorry
for kind of looking around on this hard
[ __ ] actually made this part I believe
yeah you did the search radar [ __ ]
so Harsha did this so I've seen this
only once whenever I reviewed the pull
requests and that was a little while ago
should apply input styles seeing input
okay yeah
where's our input here it is search
those okay so let's go can I throw the
style right let's try to throw it right
on the icon okay so my Tia is it's
correlation okay cool I don't think I've
had any experience with with Croatian
before so that's really it's really cool
style okay so I know I've said this
before but in case you you haven't been
around or it will you know to hear this
there are many ways to handle styles in
react so this is one of the ways that
we're doing it we're passing around
Styles like they're variables we're
bringing them into our components so we
certainly could style with regular CSS
like we're doing here all right but
we're choosing to do it another way and
that I don't know that it's settled that
there is a number one best way to do
styles yet and react that it's still
kind of wide open
so which is fun it's fun we get to try a
lot of different things it's a lot of
different opinions on on how to do it
search icon style nope that's not what I
wanted when it's search Styles there we
go all right let's say that we'll go
back here and check it out we should see
yep we see that let's open it okay and
we now have I believe conflicting styles
so let's let's actually remove this it
makes sense to remove this and you know
what let's just let's copy all of this
alright and we'll put it here and what
we want is to change this to search
styles and I'm gonna leave this on click
for now but we may end up changing that
and then we're gonna add our close icon
here and let me get rid of some of this
space cuz it just annoys me and there we
go
whoops okay all right so let's check out
what it looks like now we should be able
to see the close icon yes we can
alright the placement of that icon is
actually not bad I had envisioned it as
being on the line here so I asked within
the input but that works and we can
certainly take care of that as well with
a little bit of positioning yeah but for
now just trying to get the functionality
what we want to happen we click that oh
is it already in there yes I wondered if
that would happen
I I was hopeful I didn't want to say it
because I didn't want to sound even more
like I don't know what I'm talking about
but I was hopeful that the way Harshit
made the handle search toggle that it
would just do the opposite right of the
styles which is exactly what he did so
that was awesome and look at that so
this is the functionality that we want
the only other thing that I'm thinking
about and I'm not sure about but let me
run it by you all and let me know what
you think
previously on some of my projects I've
included a search icon sometimes on this
side sometimes on this side I can't
remember which which side I usually do
but I include a search icon my thinking
being someone may want to click
especially on mobile maybe they would
prefer to try to click some sort of icon
do you think that's a reasonable do you
think it's a reasonable thing to think
or am I just trying to build in things
that are unnecessary here I I want to
hear what you all think because I
wouldn't want to add anything into the
UI at add functionality that is not
going to improve what we have right then
it just complicates things so I I'm kind
of really leaning towards minimalistic
you know is that everything there should
have a purpose it for being there and it
should be useful to the user so anyway
so all I'll just keep checking the live
chat to see if anyone has any any input
let's see this
okay so desarrollo de desarrollo says I
think it's not necessary okay
actually let me change before I forget I
just forgot to change the title to this
[Music]
this is gonna be close close search yeah
let's do let's say closed search I would
I would much rather be more specific
here I don't I don't want anyone
thinking that if they click it it would
close everything out because you know we
do have a lot of people that that view
the bulletin that are very unfamiliar
with computers so I'd like to be as
specific as I can actually not what I
think about it I want to change the font
size for those tooltips because the
people who really need those tooltips
probably also need larger font sizes so
we'll have to look up in mature UI if
they've already thought of some way like
to pass a proper something if not we can
just change it with CSS but I'd really I
think it could be be a little larger
okay let's see
okay so Blake's in favor of the search
icon okay rook rook mentions auto focus
on the search bar that's a great idea
let's see okay John Hanson says mobile
logic for you I can be tricky only way
to really know if a button or icon to
click for a function is by using
something like Google tag manager
actually yeah I mean we could we could
put click handlers click tracking on
there just to see we put on that
Resource Center project that we did
before this I put click tracking I think
I did it it could have been somebody a
pull request if so sorry I'm not giving
you credit here but I think I put click
tracking through Google Analytics on
everything and it was pretty simple I
said I was just checking the analytics
earlier today and we had a lot of good
data on clicks and things are [ __ ] says
will you set up analytics for this yeah
we'll definitely set up analytics for
this so my the head of my department has
to go to sometimes to the president of
the the college the president University
or just in general like the board and
report on how these websites are doing
so she really likes to have data like
this like how many people click to
download this and how many people went
here right so so I always try to give as
much data as I can sometimes I never use
the data but it's good if I have it if
she comes into my office and says hey I
got a meeting in ten minutes can I have
this data then I have it and it makes me
look good and it makes her look good so
we're definitely gonna do analytics
alright so auto focus search icon auto
focus tricky sometimes forced to scroll
away somewhere you don't want a
placeholder okay all right so we have a
lot of good ideas let me try to get them
all here and just explain it so a
placeholder when you open this up that
definitely makes sense of a placeholder
here I like that
we have some conflicting opinions on
whether or not we should put a search
icon in there so let's say that for last
we may not even have time to do it no
matter what
for today's stream but let's say that
for last since we're still that somewhat
undecided on it and then also we talked
about autofocus which there's some
discussion about autofocus as well
because it can mess up the scroll
sometimes I really do like the idea of
autofocus because you know you have to
click you click search and then you have
to click here I I tell you what I'm
gonna go with autofocus but I'm gonna
keep in mind when we're testing and try
to make sure that it's not messing up
the scroll but I I'd know I would really
appreciate an autofocus because if I'm
clicking that search icon I want to
search so autofocus would be great so
let's do that so we'll do two things for
sure assuming we have time we'll set up
auto focus on click and then we will put
in some placeholder text there okay
let's see and I actually want to I may
just check this out on my other screen
quickly I just want to look at what the
search thing looks like currently on the
current bulletin and it looks like ok we
actually do let me let me just show you
this now I guess so in the current
bulletin when you click the search icon
so we actually we change the entire nav
to the search but we do actually have a
search icon and a close I wonder you
know what I think my search icon isn't
even clickable I don't thing is
clickable so I think if we just put a
placeholder that says search that'll be
fine I don't think we need the icon now
we do obviously include the close but
the search happens when the user stops
typing or something
even as they're typing depend on how
fast they're typing so I just want it to
be familiar to the users who are used to
that search so the look of it is going
to be slightly different because we're
not going with this huge search bar that
changes the whole nav but I like the
functionality to be you know identical
if possible if not at least as close as
possible just to make the transition you
know a little bit more smooth all right
so let's add where's our text field
let's see if we can just say placeholder
I don't know
I don't know what it is for material UI
which is the the UI framework that we're
using but let's try placeholder because
that makes sense if it works then we
don't have to look it up and shave some
time
yay that works ok so we have the
placeholder it goes away when you type
perfect and it comes back we don't say
excellent all right that was a great
idea yeah I think it was hard [ __ ] that
had the idea for the placeholder so
awesome let's see so that was easy and
didn't take very much time what was the
other autofocus so autofocus may take a
bit more time I don't know that I've
ever done autofocus and react now I take
that back I did I have done it before
but it's been I think I did it in March
so it's been quite a while so I will
have to look that up so let me I'll look
this up
[Music]
all right let's see let me see if anyone
has anything to say about the autofocus
okay if anyone has implemented autofocus
recently in react any help would be
appreciated otherwise I'm going to try
to look it up also he said so we have
now let me know if I'm pronouncing your
name wrong because it's written in
characters I'm not familiar with
so I'm Arabic I think but is it Ibrahim
so let me know if that's wrong but I
think it's Ibrahim but like I said the
carriers are in Arabic so I could
definitely be mistaken but anyway
Abraham says I love your channel it's
very active and then have a heart on
there so awesome I'm really glad you
love the channel and thanks for watching
and joining in in the live chat ok so
harsh it says we could just make a ref
and call focus on click oh okay
rook rook that's a that's a good idea so
harsh it's suggestion will definitely
work rook has another idea that could
save us a lot of time autofocus as a
prop so let's try to put autofocus as a
prop on the search bar rook saying
because it only appears when you click
the search icon it should be fine right
yeah yeah you're right it should be fine
because it it won't exist in the Dom at
all until you click so there's no real
danger of it accidentally being auto
focused and not visible all right let's
try that
all right
it could work it's it's such an easy fix
it's worth the try even if it doesn't
work okay so it didn't work but still
that was good thinking huh
Yunus says how did you learn Arabic I
didn't Google Translate learned Arabic
so I just think it's polite to try to
figure out someone's name even if I
don't know the characters so I know for
me it would I would feel good if
somebody took the time to do that so
anyway so I think it's worth it so on my
other screen I Google translated it so
unfortunately I don't know Arabic Oh
hard [ __ ] you're right you're right my
mistake I missed I mistakenly said that
this wouldn't exist but in fact it does
because the way Harshit made it it's
it's only using display:none it's not
actually removing a component so my
mistake I usually do stuff like that
where I make the components actually
completely be gone you know be rendered
or not rendered based on on the prop so
anyway so yeah so that might be an issue
but let's try I guess I guess it's worth
the shot just to check the material UI
and see if they have some built-in way
of handling something like this it could
save us some time so let's try it out
let's see that's what we're using right
textfield yes okay
autofocus oh okay cool so autofocus does
work we just needed to camelcase it so
let's see let's try this again
autofocus
you know what that's not gonna work
because it autofocuses when the
component mounts but then I'm clicking
away so that's that will undo the focus
so actually let's let's see I wonder if
this will work no I didn't I was
wondering if when I typed it would
actually go in here even before so let's
let's switch this up a bit
I'm not gonna have time for this shoot
okay so in case I don't do this on the
stream and I do it before tomorrow
stream actually I'm not gonna stream
tomorrow I'll give you more info about
that in a second I'm not gonna have
enough time before my meeting to
implement this but here's my plan right
now when you do handle search toggle and
when you click a button that fires off
handle search toggle it's just changing
the CSS from display blow up to
display:none you know back and forth
what I want to have happen instead is
that this text field actually renders on
you know on on click so what will end up
having will have to pass down will have
to change up a little bit about what's
going on with our state and then make
sure we pass it down like we're going
with these search styles and then we're
gonna have to adjust our handle search
toggle function that resides in our
index J s within our layout folder but
the end result is going to be that we're
gonna end up having some sort of ternary
that is gonna check the state which the
statement might end up being like show
show search input or something which
will just be a boolean and so we'll end
up having something like
show search and then if we are showing
search we'll put all of that in here
right will show this otherwise will show
this so actually I won't do it like this
I'll end up doing it like a question
mark okay I am hearing the beeping sound
now my pummelo recession is up and then
we'll put this and actually might have
time to do this so this is what'll end
up happening and so right now it's going
to break because I don't actually have
so sure show search being passed down as
a prop but what we'll end up doing is in
index will add show search by default
it's going to be false okay so and then
where we have our top bar we're gonna
pass on so show search equals this state
dot show search and then now
that's what's inside of a closer
official we got to wrap it yes we can't
have this so let's just wrap this in a
div oops and this should be good yeah so
sure it's just not defined and I didn't
bring it in here
so let's let's destructure a little bit
here show search alright now it should
work okay so he had something happen
which I'm gonna take is a win right now
since I just tried to do that as fast as
I possibly could
yeah what should happen so this is
yeah I don't know what went wrong but I
don't have time to check it out right
now but you can see basically that the
concept that I'm trying to go for and
the reason being I think we could get
this autofocus to work if if we can have
this actually this component render when
you click the search icon because I
believe this autofocus fires when the
component mounts so we want to delay the
mounting until the user actually clicks
on that icon so anyway that's the idea
obviously something's weird about it
right now since it's not showing at all
but we get that fixed it could be
something as simple as wrapping it in a
div somehow change the Styles not sure
okay let me try quickly to go through
the live chat and answer all your
questions and let's see I'm try to find
where I left off
okay so hard should has pasted a link to
a gist that has a debate about CSS and
react and how to use it so anyway that
looks really really helpful
let's check and bring it over here so oh
I'll paste the link in the chat as well
so it's clickable for you all it's way
too long of a link for me to actually
read out to anybody that can't see the
live chat so sorry for that if someone
wants to put in a comment to the video
that would be awesome I'll make sure it
gets approved a lot of times if you try
to paste a link in a comment to the
video it gets flagged as spam but I'll
go in and approve it okay so look at all
the different ways to do this so really
cool thanks for sharing that hardship
abstract cat says this seems like a cool
learn session as well for those of us
just learning I started learning web
design about ten years ago that
distracted but now going full steam
ahead
awesome awesome that's that that kind of
sounds like like me as well I learned
some some web development in in high
school and then didn't really do that
much with it till so much later on so
I'm trying to think actually 10 years
might be it might be about the same 10
years so yeah well hopefully you learn
stuff I do my best to try to explain
things that I think might be confusing
to people who are just starting out or
not familiar with react so you know I
don't always I'm sure I just skip over
some things and don't realize that it's
I should probably explain but when I
when I remember I really try to explain
as well as I can
let's see
I'm scrolling through the chat here
there's one out a whole lot of questions
there's a lot of a lot of stuff I
already kind of went over when we were
kind of going back and forth trying to
find solutions to this autofocus thing
Josh Modi'in says for the closed search
you could try to make it so that when
the user clicks off it closes yeah yeah
definitely I think that's I actually
have thought about that I'm gonna think
when I was thinking about it earlier and
I there was some reason why I thought
maybe I shouldn't do it and I can't
remember now I can't believe I care
however I'll have to try to think about
it but that's that's actually not a bad
idea
well Harsha said it should have played
the audio it did it did play the audio
this time so that that Pomodoro timer I
heard it
oh okay John B says try autofocus true I
could try that yeah I mean I I assumed
that I could just put it in there and it
would automatically be true usually you
can do that okay yeah so maybe oh I'll
try that out probably sometime tomorrow
I click opposed all right Harsha says
commit this PR immediately so did you
submit a pull request now
No let's see Chinese okay
Philip says I haven't started I started
learning JavaScript but went probably
too fast since I missed a lot of the
vanilla JavaScript but I work full-time
with react now should I fill my missing
basic JavaScript knowledge yeah I I
think it's it's always good to have good
knowledge of JavaScript so if you if you
can get your work done and it's good
work then I wouldn't make it you know a
huge priority to fill that in but it
might not be a bad idea to just go
through some of the basics a little bit
every day even if it's only a few
minutes I think that you know that would
be good because you never know react is
is certainly relevant now and I think it
will be for at least a few more years
but you never know what'll happen in the
future and the more JavaScript plain
vanilla JavaScript you know the better
you'll be able to adapt to any
JavaScript based system that comes up so
yeah so probably don't need to learn it
right now you know not this month I'm
not even this year but if you do a
little bit at a time you I think you'll
set yourself up to be able to to adapt
to changes and make sure that you know
you can still do good work no matter
what happens
so okay horse should I get it horse is
saying I should commit this okay cool
yeah let me commit this then and then
I'm gonna have to wrap things up so I
have to go to my meeting but
okay that looks good tomorrow I'm not
gonna stream so I was looking at my
calendar earlier and I just have so many
meetings tomorrow that in in they're
spaced out so that I have like an hour
between meetings so there's not really a
great time for me to to do a stream I
mean the only possibility would be if
somehow I got into work really early and
then did a morning stream I don't think
that's gonna happen so on the off chance
that I do get in really early maybe I'll
do that otherwise most likely not gonna
stream but Wednesday is looking good for
a stream I currently have no meeting
scheduled so I think Wednesday is like
nearly for sure there's going to be a
stream unless something weird happens
but tomorrow probably no stream and if I
there is one it will probably be in
early morning Eastern Time so anyway I
have to go okay I should just said git
push origin master thanks I I may have
forgotten that actually I probably would
have just immediately gone right to my
meeting and forgotten to push that so oh
cool all right Gideon's back so Gideon
says been away for a while it's not easy
meeting up with internet connection
inconsistencies I missed everyone but
it's good to be back home
awesome hey really glad to see you in
the chat I hope everything's going well
for you okay so now I do have to go oh I
have to go to a meeting in a few minutes
but I really enjoyed this
dream it was really cool definitely a
lot of new people in the chat that I
haven't gotten to talk to yet so I'm
really excited about that and yeah so
hopefully you learned something and I we
got some cool stuff done so yeah so I
guess I'll see you most likely on
Wednesday and until then have a great
two days